En qué está fallando la comunidad
internacional a la hora de cumplir con
esos ambiciosos objetivos de los
acuerdos de París la ONU dice que los
pasos que se han dado hasta ahora son
insuficientes
Muchas gracias por esta invitación
definitivamente los compromisos
nacionales
que asumen los países para el
cumplimiento del acuerdo de París lo que
hemos visto es que cuando los hemos
contado hemos visto que estamos en un
aumento de las emisiones de gases de
efecto invernadero los causantes del
cambio climático de alrededor de un
10,6% para el año 2030 cuando para el
año 2030 deberíamos tener una reducción
de un 45% de estas emisiones Entonces
esto lo que significa es que con los
compromisos actuales de los países
estamos en prácticamente un 2,5 grados
de calentamiento global al año 2050
Entonces esto es incumplir el acuerdo de
París Y si ahora mismo con 1,1 grados de
calentamiento que estamos a día de hoy
ya tenemos los efectos dramáticos que
estamos viendo en el en la agricultura
Los Huracanes el momento el nivel del
mar incendios etcétera etcétera pues te
puedes imaginar lo que significaría
estos 2,5ºc
Hay algún aspecto positivo sobre cómo ha
cambiado nuestros hábitos sobre estas
emisiones que se destaquen en este
informe
bueno el año anterior el año pasado
teníamos una predicción de un aumento de
un 14%. Entonces el bajarlo a un 10,6
digamos que es una mejora sin embargo es
una mejora que es todavía muy
insuficiente y lo que también hace un
informe Paralelo que ha sido también
presentado hoy también por un cambio
climático es que analiza las estrategias
a largo plazo que es otro tipo de
informes que presentan los países al
convenio de cambio climático para ver a
2050 pues como Cómo es su planificación
de reducción de emisiones y ahí vemos
Que a ese largo plazo sí que tienes una
reducción sustancial lo que pasa es que
esto va a depender de que todas estas
políticas inversiones y compromisos se
pongan en práctica que los países
verdaderamente no den Un paso atrás
con este panorama que podemos esperar de
la cop 27 que comienza ya el próximo 6
de noviembre en shalom Shake
la copa 27 es una cop o Debería ser una
Cup de implementación Los acuerdos ya
han sido cerrados ahora se trata de
venir y hablar cómo vamos a implementar
ese compromiso de 1,5 grados entonces lo
que esperamos es que los jefes de estado
los ministros de todos los países del
Mundo vengan a hablar como lo van a
hacer a nivel práctico porque está claro
que a nivel teórico en lo que nos han
presentado son insuficientes los
compromisos